look guys here it is and I'm gonna be
matter-of-fact about this if you ever
find a couple of creepy little Dirty
Gollum children in the middle of nowhere
you're gonna be in for a bad day that's
just the fact of the matter that whisper
in the trailer creepy so long story
short with no spoilers mom was the story
of a couple little creepy kids who are
in the woods they were raised in the
woods by nothing or they were raised by
and then they get found so who's gonna
be the caretaker of these children well
Jessica Chastain and King Slayer from
Game of Thrones of course who else so
now we have our story now mom is a mixed
bag there's stuff to like stuff or
you're like a a cliche it's
ultimately a movie about an apparition
that haunts a house do you have seen
that a hundred times before however I
give this movie credit because it does
try to throw some new stuff into the mix
what really work for me are these creepy
kids 99% of the time in this movie if
there's something that actually creeps
you out it has nothing to do with the
ghosts it actually has to do with the
little kids when I call a little golem
Smeagol kids that's exactly what they
are they walk like Gollum they walk on
all fours they'll perch in the dark on
the fridge and just stare at you yeah
you're creeped out just imagining it in
your head it was really well done in the
movie there's an interesting social
aspect in the movie about these kids who
weren't raised by anybody they were just
in the woods and they survived because
mama fed them cherries now they act like
animals that's actually really
interesting to me movie has a couple of
jump-scares it has the average amount of
jump scares without being the complete
jump scare fest couple of times I was
like I would think that's a jump scare
but it was it was executed differently
so I don't actually consider it a jump
scare well played but then the movie
takes a gamble and you're forced to
actually connect with Jessica Chastain
in this movie good actress yes but was
her character in this movie a complete
washed-up selfish dickbag yes she was
she was kind of selfish and and
you're like I don't like you thirty
eight-year-old GarageBand jack for half
the movie I wanted mama to like throw
her on the garbage disposal but you know
you go on with the movie and you realize
that the movies about her growing as a
person and connecting with these kids
and the movie ends up pulling that off
but until it does for half the movie
you're like I don't like this check mama
throw her in the dryer there are a
couple shots and scenes in this movie
where I was like that was really cool
good job but after that has this
apparition haunted house horror movie
cliches and you're like all right
I've seen this before there's a ghost
and it's haunting them and that's that
yet for most of the movie you don't
actually see mama and I think that's
really cool but when you see mom at a
point in the movie of course they're
gonna be like okay here is mama and all
of her CGI glory and after that it just
ceases to be creepy and scary fear of
the unknown is what drives movies like
this once you show everything it's kind
of lost and everything they set up to be
factual in the movie and then the end
happens because they just feel like they
had to make an ending that really was
like oh wow but it wasn't you I was just
kind of like it endings one of these
endings that makes me walk out of a
movie like this and be like it's no big
deal
so was mama enjoyable yes it was did it
have creepy parts yes it did where the
kids really good in the movie and were
they interesting yes they were does the
movie have originality yes it does is
the movie riddled with unassisted house
horror movie cliches absolutely do you
walk out of the movie feeling like I've
seen something completely new kind of
but not enough I will say I enjoyed the
movie enough to say mama is a good time
no alcohol required I feel like there
should be a subtext of it matinee price
I feel like if I would pay full price on
a Friday or Saturday night I would walk
out of this movie going well there goes
that evening that weekend evening that I
will never get back but I give mama
credit and going in a new enough
direction while holding to the fact that
it is a haunted house movie so what is
your favorite haunted house movie
whatever it may be comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you